demon souls on ps5 is a remake of the
2009
from software original and it's hard
very hard
newcomers are going to need a few
pointers to survive the world of
bulletaria and it never hurts to
remember the fundamentals even if you've
already beaten the game
with that in mind we've put together
some tips that will help make your
opening hours and demon souls
a bit more manageable pick your starting
choices carefully
you'll first need to create your
character and choose a starting class
by using the souls of fallen enemies to
level up and amplify critical stats you
can evolve your character in any way you
see fit
so a humble barbarian has the means to
evolve into
a magic wielding glass cannon by the
game's end
still your choices at the start can have
a significant impact on your chances of
survival
for beginners the knight soldier temple
knight and royal classes
are solid picks as they cover all the
basic stats
and have reliable weapons and armor to
back them up
after you pick a starting class you can
also choose a starting item
we'd recommend picking the providential
ring which will increase
luck and raise the drop rates of healing
items and crafting materials
this is really helpful in the early
hours of the game
get to know the nexus and keep it safe
after meeting your inevitable first
death in the introduction
and losing both your body and collected
souls you'll find yourself
whisked to the nexus this main hub is
where you'll meet the game's key
characters and merchants who offer
help on your quest here you can upgrade
your equipment
and manage your inventory the nexus's
most important character
is the maiden in black who will help
players level up with collected souls
as you proceed through each archstone
you can bring additional characters back
to the nexus who can offer you new items
magic spells and other insights on
places to explore
depending on your choices though you may
set events into motion
that can put your allies at risk so be
sure to keep the nexus safe for your
allies to preserve your line to
resources
don't be afraid to explore elsewhere
unlike the dark souls series's winding
interconnected levels demon's souls has
five standalone worlds that are all
tied to the nexus inside the nexus you
can travel to each location in the game
from one of five archstones
which open up after defeating the
phalanx boss in the boletarian palace
it is important to stress that you are
not expected to complete each archstone
before moving on to the next
once you've defeated a boss in one realm
and unlock the next waypoint
you've essentially completed the first
chapter it's a much better use of your
time to head out to a new location and
progress
there while it's possible to keep
proceeding forward
you'll quickly find that the monsters in
each section are much more challenging
so don't be afraid to venture off to a
new space if you feel like you've hit a
wall
[Music]
only take what you need inventory
management is just as essential in demon
souls as swordplay and careful dodging
depending on your character's endurance
you'll find that items will eventually
begin to affect
your character's movement and what they
can pick up an inventory that hasn't
been managed can be especially
troublesome when you find a valuable
item
but can't pick it up because you've run
out of room in the nexus you can talk
with stockpile thomas
to access the game's storage boxes
allowing you to offload spare items
unused gear and crafting materials early
on it's best to ditch things that you
don't need
and place them inside one fantastic
quality of life improvement with the
demon souls remake is that you can
instantly send items to the storage box
if your character's weight limit has
been reached while this can still
prevent you from
using certain items at the moment it
does take the sting
out of missing out on valuables forever
leave a helpful message behind a
hallmark of the souls games is their
communication system
which players can use to leave helpful
messages or vague notes in the
environments for others to find
the remake of demon souls has the
original's messaging system attacked
and given the incredibly harsh stakes in
the opening hours
paying attention to these notes while
also using your best judgment
is key to survival using the touch pad
you can select the option to leave a
message based on a preset list of
keywords
besides being a great way to help fellow
dungeoneers
it also allows you to get a sudden
health boost if another player gives it
a positive affirmation
this can potentially be a massive help
in a tough boss battle
so be sure to leave messages and like
those left by others when you can
know your world tendency one of demon's
soul's more
intricate features is the world tendency
system
the systems move between white or black
tendencies
and these alter the way you explore
dungeons and fight
enemies for instance exploring dungeons
with black world tendency will result in
more
aggressive enemies and more frequent
black phantoms invading your world
however black world tendency will also
lead to higher drop rates for specific
items
which adds some incentive to stick with
the added challenge
what made this feature such a strange
system in the original was how
vague it was thankfully the remake makes
the world tendency system a bit more
evident with the inclusion of a new menu
that shows off the balance of each realm
coming to grips with world tendency will
not only make it easier for you to
understand your current odds but it will
also allow you to understand
how to tip the balance in your favor
be patient and always be prepared for a
fight
despite its uncompromising approach to
combat
demon's souls is largely a fair game
when it comes to each encounter in boss
fight
the trick is understanding that you'll
need to think several steps ahead before
you engage in a battle
it's never a pleasant sight to meet your
death especially when it costs
thousands of souls but each one is a
learning opportunity
the keys to overcoming the many
challenges in demon souls
are perseverance patience and
understanding the threats
you face combat is one of the core
pillars of the game
and while the introduction will walk you
through various ins and outs of standard
attacks and defensive skills
sometimes it's much better to let your
enemies wear themselves out
and then rush behind them for a backstab
when they're catching their breath
the moment-to-moment experience of
playing demon souls can be tense and
challenging
so always take a second before an
encounter to analyze what's to come
these tips should help you overcome the
difficulties of demon souls but if you
have any other pointers
be sure to share them with your fellow
warriors in the comments below
and remember to visit gamespot for all
the best demon souls coverage